[Music]
well greetings everyone thank you for
joining our program i'd like to know
this is a weekly program where we answer
the questions that you the television
audience send us
you can send us any question that you
have concerning the scriptures
concerning the bible and we will do the
research we'll try to find an answer and
if there is an answer we will definitely
share it with you
on our program i'd like to know let me
give you the email address where you can
send us the questions it's tv at some
tv.org once again tv at some tv.org
and we would be elated to receive your
questions it leads us to study the bible
and to find answers i have with me
pastor daniel miranda
who
is the co-host of this program
and he is the host of the spanish
program me gustavia zaver
and thank you for being willing to work
bilingually
in this very interesting program praise
the lord it is
actually a blessing to me i love this
program it really pushes me to study
more praise very good and deep questions
that they send us amen likewise it kind
of stretches my
intellect to the max
with some of the questions especially
that come in
we never should uh start answering
questions from god's word uh unless we
pray first amen and so i would like to
ask you to have a word of prayer to ask
the lord to bless this pleasure let's
pray
dear heavenly father what a privilege
to be part of this program what a
privilege to be used by you to answer
bible questions thank you for this
opportunity to delve into your word and
go deeper and find answers to your
people who are hungering and thirsting
for righteousness we pray lord that you
may
guide us with your holy spirit as we
go through the scriptures and try to
find
these answers we pray all these in the
name of jesus amen amen
okay now we have a question which
actually is two questions in one
and it comes from ana lugube
i hope i didn't massacre that name there
have many you know we have many viewers
in africa yeah
and many of these names in europe also
yeah i'm sure that yeah
actually
we have many from europe as well yes
so
we hope that we're pronouncing the names
uh the way that they should be
pronounced if not uh send us a comment
and we will try to correct the
pronunciation uh the question is this
good day pastors
when
are our names written in the book of
life
and then the second part of the question
and when are our names removed from the
book of life
good question
ellen y has some quotes
very clear statements about this but i
always like to play the bible the
biblical foundation
because
ellen white doesn't say anything that is
not in the bible right now we don't find
a text that clearly says that but we
find indications to that for example in
philippians chapter 4
philippians chapter 4 we read from verse
we're going to read verse
philippians chapter 4 verse 3.
the bible says here and i urge you also
true companion
help these women who labored with me in
the gospel notice these are women who
are laboring with paul in the gospel
with clement also
and the rest of my fellow workers
whose names are in the book of life
so we see we find an indication here of
those who are in the service of god in
the gospel and if they're in the service
of god that means that they have already
accepted god in their lives right so
when our names written the book of life
when we are converted when we become
children of god when we are baptized
and when we enter into the service
of god i find i have a quote here from
signs of the times
august 6
18 1885
it says when we become children of god
our names are written in the lamb's book
of life
and they remain there
until the time of the investigative
judgment
okay and then in the investigative
it will be revealed whether our name
should be retained correct in the book
of life
you know some people have the idea that
when we confess our sin our names are
written in the book of life but when we
sin they're blotted out yeah god is
writing and erasing writing and erasing
but that's not how it works that's right
it's actually when our names are
called upon in the day of judgment
that
our names will be immoralized or blotted
out from the book of life yeah you know
the interesting thing is
you know sometimes there are in
scripture
and in the writings of ellen white
things that appear and i want to
underline that word up here appear to be
contradictory
in other words the bible says one thing
ellen white says another let me give you
an example of that
in
what we find in revelation chapter 17
and verse 8.
it says the beast that you saw was
and is not
and will ascend out of the bottomless
pit and go to perdition
and those who dwell on the earth will
marvel
whose names are not written
in the book of life
from the foundation of the world
when they see the beast that was and is
not and yet is so it speaks here of
individuals names that were not written
in the book of life from the foundation
of the world before sin
but then ellen white
has this statement where she tells us
when our names are written in the book
of life
so are they written
in the book of life before the
foundation of the world and other names
are not written before the foundation of
the world or are they written at the
moment of baptism well ellen white
explains this is in the book god's
amazing grace page 143 let those who
receive the imprint of god by baptism
heed these words it's talking about the
words this is my beloved son and who am
i am well pleased when jesus was
baptized
so let those who receive the imprint of
god by baptism he these words
remembering that upon them the lord has
placed his signature
by baptism declaring them to be his sons
and daughters
the father the son and the holy ghost
powers infinite omniscient receive those
who truly enter into covenant relation
with god
they are present at every baptism that
is father son and holy spirit to receive
the candidates who have renounced the
world and have received christ into the
soul temple
these candidates have entered into the
family of god and their names are
inscribed in the lamb's book of life
so when are
those who are baptized when are those
names of those who accept christ
placed in the book of life it's at the
moment that they're baptized correct
when they become members of the family
of god
but in revelation 17 verse 8
it says that though that names are not
written from the before the foundation
of the world which would lead us to
assume that there are names that are
written uh from the foundation of the
world so how do we deal with this well
the fact is
we need to understand
that
god has a perspective of time and we
have a perspective of time
from the perspective of god
they were written before the foundation
of the world he knows the end from the
beginning because god knew the choice
that god's people were going to make
correct
but
from our perspective
they are written the moment that we're
baptized when it actually happens um
ellen white has this interesting
statement um in desire of ages 606 god
counts the things that are not
as though they were
he sees the end from the beginning and
beholds the result of his work as though
it were now accomplished
the precious dead from adam down to the
last saint who dies will hear the voice
of the son of god and will come forth
from the grave to immortal life god will
be their god and they shall be his
people there will be a close and tender
relationship between god and the risen
saints
this condition which is anticipated in
his purpose
he beholds as if it were already
existing
the dead live unto him
so
this is in the discussion with the
sadducees
where
you know the sadducees come in and
present this uh outrageous scenario
about the seven marriages you know and
uh who the person is going to be married
with uh in the kingdom come
and um and so god so jesus says all live
to him
at that point
abraham isaac and jacob were dead
for those who were there
but to him
abraham isaac and jacob at that moment
were alive because god lives in an
eternal presence he lives in a different
time dimension we can also notice this
uh with jesus
jesus was slain
from the foundation of the world
he said now wait a minute he was
actually slain in the year 31 on a
friday afternoon at three o'clock in the
afternoon so how do you reconcile that
he's the lamb of god slain from before
the foundation of the world and
that he actually is slain in the year
31. well the fact is from god's
perspective it was a done deal from
before the foundation of the world from
our perspective it happened in the year
31 on a friday afternoon at 3 o'clock in
the afternoon
in another statement ellen white wrote
manuscript releases volume 14 page 22
and 23
i am means an eternal presence
the past present and future are alike to
god
so from god's perspectives our names
were in there
he knew what our choice was going to be
before the foundation of the world but
from our perspective it actually
empirically happens when we're baptized
so there's no contradiction she
continues god sees the most remote
events of past history
and the far distant future
with as clear a vision as we do those
things that are transpiring daily before
our eyes so god's perspective in ours is
totally different
and there's an example another example
of this in genesis 17
verses 4 and 5
where
god presents the two perspectives in
verse 4 god is speaking to abram he says
as for me behold my covenant is with you
and you shall be a father of many
nations
so that's abraham's perspective of time
but then in verse 5 god says no longer
shall your name be called abram but your
name shall be called abraham for i have
made you a father of many nations
and somebody might say well you know
that you're just nitpicking there but
the apostle paul picked up on this in
romans chapter 4
and he quotes in verse 17 as it is
written i have made you the father many
nations he is our father in the presence
of god whom he believed the god who
makes the dead alive
and summons the things that do not yet
exist as though they already do
so from god's perspective
he had already made abraham the father
of many nations from abraham's
perspective god was going to make him a
father of many nations
albert barnes the great bible
commentator explained it this way that
is those things which he foretells and
promises
are so certain
that he may speak of them as already in
existence
thus in relation to abraham god instead
of simply promising that he would make
him the father of many nations speak of
it speaks of it as already done right i
have made thee in his own mind or
purpose he had so constituted him and it
was so certain that it would take place
that he might speak of it as already
done
yeah and just to be clear
we're not talking about predestination
no we're talking about god's
foreknowledge
god knew the choice that people were
going to make correct but the choice is
theirs
god doesn't choose people to be saved
and lost but god knows who's going to be
choosing to be saved or to be lost
correct now the second part of questions
is and when our names will be removed
from the book of life okay well acts 3
18 or 3 19 i believe
uh here's what the bible says
acts 3
the bible says repent therefore and be
converted that your sins may be blooded
out
so that times of refreshing may come
from the presence of the lord
so here we see a blotting out of sin
by implication also there is a
uh removing of names from the book of
life some linguists say some names are
taken some names are right are left
in the book
and this is happening here when
so that the times of refreshing may come
from the presence of the lord actually
the time of the blotting out of sins in
heaven is parallel to the time of the
ceiling here on earth and the latter
rain so it is during that time that
the names are being removed
from the book of life and also
our names on our or our sins
are being blotted out right from the
book of records so it takes place during
the investigative judgment correct which
began with the dead in 1844
and continues and ends with the judgment
of the living right before the close of
probation yes that's when the names are
actually either removed or retained in
the book of life
exactly one added thing which is not
particularly in the question
ellen white does mention a book of death
those who did not pass the test in the
investigative judgment i'd like to read
that statement early writings 290 and
then i saw thrones and jesus and the
redeemed saints sat upon them this is
during the millennium
thus and the saints reigned as kings and
priests unto god christ in union with
his people judged the wicked dead
comparing their acts with a statute
statute book the word of god
and deciding every case according to the
deeds done in the body
then that is the righteous meted out the
wit to the wicked the portion which they
must suffer
according to their works
and it was written against their names
in the book of death
so
the
names
of those individuals who did not pass
the test
in the pre-admin investigative judgment
namely the wicked their names will be
examined during the thousand years and
then
they are written in the book of death
according and also registered there is
the punishment that must be suffered
at that time right
all right now we have another question
here we have still a few minutes left
i don't get this right
is it true that women should always
discover
should always yeah
cover their heads in church or what is
paul really addressing
um you know this question we already
answered a long time ago and i'd like to
know can you explain how people can
access the earlier programs sure so
there are two ways at least in which you
can go back and
access to our previous programs one is
going to our youtube channel
some tv and go to videos and you will be
able to find the previous programs from
this year last year and the previous
year and so forth
there are playlists as well that would
be a quick
search through the playlists
but an easier way would be to download
our app not the secrets and still app
although you should download that one as
well but the new app that we have that
was recently released it's some tb up
there you should be able to find all our
programs including this program with the
questions that have already been
answered you can search
and find everything that you need there
so we really highly encourage you to
download our app it's for free that's
the good news about it
you can find pastor boar sermons and the
syllables the manuals and you can watch
the sermon along with the notes and in
that way you can follow through
so
download our app and
may may be a blessing to you
the next question has also come up in
the past
and i'm quite certain that uh this
question was answered uh in a previous
program uh this is sent to us from
ethiopia interestingly enough uh from
bedani
bedani bentulu
in ethiopia
and i'll just read the question my
question will be about the christmas
tree
in adventist home page 482 paragraph one
ellen white wrote god would be well
pleased if on christmas each
christmas each church
would have a christmas tree on which
shall be hung offerings great and small
for these houses of worship
therefore what is the background on
which e.g white said this
and if we are allowed to do this
doesn't this promote
idol worship in our churches maybe we
need to address the idol worship aspect
here by having a christmas tree in the
church would it be idol worship to have
according to ellen white's
recommendation a christmas tree in the
church
no because she certainly clarified that
this was not to worship
she said that we could turn
what the world does with with christmas
time and we can turn it into a blessing
and we can put the tree to encourage
church members to bring gifts to give to
god's work to the needy
so in this sense this is not idol
worship the fact that something that was
used as an idol before
is used today doesn't mean that we are
worshiping an idol
and that's something really important
when we when we come to christmas and
other holidays and practices the fact
that something is used or was used as an
idol
by other people
doesn't mean that the use of that
particular thing itself constitutes
idolatry in the case in this case
the christmas tree
first corinthians 8 says uh if something
is an idol for you let it be an idol for
you but
also respect the matter of conscience of
other people
some people were offended in the church
of current because
of eating foods offered to idols but
some others who had knowledge
for them that was not an issue
right and paul was encouraging respect
in regards to people's conscience if
something is an idol for you or is an
issue then we should respect brothers
conscience those who are weak
but if for for some others it is not an
issue we should also respect that yeah
you know it kind of kind of reminds me a
little bit about something that's
happening these days
when you get on an airplane these days
the pilot or the flight attendant comes
on the loudspeaker and says you know
masks are no longer
no longer mandated on the flights uh so
if you want to wear a mask those who
don't wear a mask respect the one who
wears a mask or the one who doesn't wear
a mask respect the one who wears the
mask so basically it's respect for other
people's conscience and other people's
convictions
the fact is that
you know i've pastored many churches and
in some of those churches i put up a
christmas tree
to do what ellen white recommended that
is for people to bring their offings and
put them on the tree thus showing that
they're dedicating to them to jesus i've
never seen a case where people actually
bow down and worship the tree correct or
people really think that that they're
worshiping the tree by having a tree
there it's kind of like having uh the
christian flag there you know we don't
uh
kneel before the christian flag and the
american flag here in the united states
is usually on the platform in churches
it doesn't mean that we're idolizing the
united states of america
so
you know just having a tree on the
platform does not necessarily involve
worship i haven't seen anybody
worshiping a christmas tree correct so
there are some bigger things in church
that can become or in our own lives that
can become idols yeah it's a lot of
money and uh
vanity
selfishness pride yeah and those are
more serious idols that we should be
careful with and those are the sins that
we don't emphasize yes the internal
sense
you know the greed covetousness
and things like that
we usually rebuke only actions
but not
the root
where those actions come from
okay now this next question we don't
really have enough time
to answer the following question
it's by
gatluach jacques cole
i have no idea where this person is from
that is one of those names that is very
difficult to pronounce
i hope that i pronounce it correctly but
this one deals with um let me just read
the question and then maybe we'll come
back to it in our next program i have a
question first let me tell you about my
understanding on this issue as a
seventh-day adventist we know that when
jesus comes the promise of john 14 1-3
will be fulfilled as jesus will take us
to heaven to where his father is and
there we will spend a thousand years and
saints will participate in judgment and
after the thousand years has expired
jesus and the redeemed with the holy
city will descend to earth and then at
that moment the second resurrection will
take place the wicked of all ages will
surround the holy city and fire will
fall down from heaven and will devour
sinners and after that the sinners are
destroyed according to their works done
in the body ultimately god will create a
new heavens and earth where
righteousness will dwell where no sin is
present with the new jerusalem as a
capital city of the universe okay that's
the preamble to the question
and the person has everything correct
correct i mean this is all theologically
correct in harmony with the bible and
the spirit of prophecy but now comes the
question which we really don't have time
to answer in this program
and that is
but in isaiah 65 20.
it seems like there's going to be death
and a curse
while in the new earth those things will
never be present according to revelation
21 3 and 4 and revelation 22 3 and in
isaiah 65 20 the bible seems to explain
this in context of the new earth so what
is your thought on this as a theologian
so how do we deal with this issue very
briefly because we're going to come back
to it very briefly exactly yeah i have
gotten this question many times we need
to understand something when we study
classical prophecy like the case of the
book of isaiah classical prophecy is a
prophecy that was given to time the time
of the prophet uh that
the first fulfillment is local and
literal
uh this is a conditional prophecy that
god gave to israel
if they had followed the lord if they
had kept god's commandments god would
have restored them as a great nation and
even would have given them longevity
that's that's the promise that we find
here in isaiah 65
20. no more shall an infant from there
live but a few days nor an old man who
has not fulfilled his days for the child
shall die 100 years old but the sinner
being 100 years old shall be accursed
so
clearly this is not
directly talking to in the context
of
the new heavens and the new earth but
what revelation does is that it picks on
this language
and now gives it an eschatological
dimension
uh
to the end of times
but the literal and local
interpretation of this passage is
with literal israel if they had kept the
covenant
and uh
and obey the commandments of the lord
but definitely there's not going to be
curse there's not going to be death in
the new heavens and the new earth so
this is a conditional prophecy was never
fulfilled literally but it will be
fulfilled
spiritually and worldwide with spiritual
israel
without the the curse and without the
death
okay so uh basically it is in the
context of the new heavens and north it
is in the country because verse 17 says
for behold i create new heavens and new
earth and the former shall not be
remembered or come to mind so and then
afterwards you have this verse uh
another verse which is uh very
appears to be very complicated and i'll
just throw this out
for the next program even though it's
not one of the questions that is asked
we usually read
isaiah 66 22 and 23
and we say you know that
from sabbath to sabbath we're going to
worship before the lord and from month
to month we're going to go worship
before the lord but we seem to ignore
verse 24.
we apply 22 and 23 to the future but we
kind of
you know shovel uh verse 4 24 under the
rug
because it seems to say that when we're
going sabbath the sabbath and month to
month you know we're going to see the
carcasses of the people outside the holy
city so that's also a verse that we're
going to have to come to terms with in
our next program very good and so we'll
deal with both of these verses but thank
you for the introduction to them well
our time is up thank you for being with
us god bless you hope to see you in the
next program i'd like to know blessings
[Music]
you